Hi, everyone.
Great to be here.
My name is Bar Moses.
I'm the CEO and cofounder of
Monte Carlo,
the data reliability
platform. And today,
I am stoked to
have a chat with
you all about how to eliminate
data downtime and
start trusting
your data. Hopefully,
you all can see my screen,
and we're gonna
get started here.
So just a little
bit of background
about myself. As I mentioned,
CEO of Monte Carlo.
Prior to Monte Carlo,
I worked at a company
called Gainsight,
worked mostly
with companies to
help them become data driven,
to actually make
use of their data,
for various, purposes.
I, am also in the process of
writing the very first book on
data quality in collaboration
with O'Reilly. Super
excited about that.
We just prereleased,
so the very first chapter.
So check that out
if you'd like.
And then another
fun fact about
me is that I'm a very big,
fan of Bruce Willis movies.
So you'll you'll find me,
watching those in
my spare time,
when I'm not
thinking about data
downtime. So that's just
introduction about myself.
Again, stoked to
be here and to
speak with you all about data
downtime and data
observability.
So let's get started.
What is the problem that we're
all here today to discuss?
The problem is what we call
the good pipeline's
bad data problem.
And what does this
actually mean?
Everyone on this call probably
has some experience
working with,
data lakes, data
warehouses, ETL,
reverse ETL, BI
models, ML models.
Whatever you'd like,
we have all the acronyms.
In short, everyone,
typically most companies,
have invested a lot in setting
up world class,
best in class
data infrastructure
and data systems.
And so we're all
sort of ingesting,
processing,
transforming, modeling,
making great use of the data.
But here's the problem.
We've invested so
much in having
amazing pipelines and amazing
data infrastructure.
However, so often
the data that's
actually powering
those systems
is often wrong.
Not sure if anyone
here, today,
you know, the example
here is familiar.
You know, you kinda wake up
Monday morning,
you come into the office or
maybe you log into
your office,
and you suddenly get sort of
slammed with this,
you know, this,
like, meteor,
shower of pings
from Slack asking,
what's wrong with my report?
Or, hey. It looks
like the data
here doesn't quite
look right.
What am I missing?
Or, you know, get pinged.
What what type of,
what data what,
table should I be using?
What what is right for this
question that I'm
trying to answer?
And it's always at
the very last minute.
It's always, like,
four minutes
before a meeting.
Or, you you know,
if you get lucky,
it might be on
a Friday night,
as well. In any case,
this sort of
situation is really
widespread across
the industry.
There isn't anyone that isn't
hit by this. For
me in particular,
I experienced this when I was
managing a data team,
at Gainsight,
and we were, you know,
sort of hit by lots
of questions.
Know, I felt like, oh, man.
We had, like, one
job to do right.
It was get the data right.
And we, you know,
we weren't able to do that.
It was really,
really hard to do.
And I think there's
many reasons
for that. Right?
There's, you know,
way way more data that we're
managing today.
There's way more
stakeholders,
and and data is, a lot
more distributed,
in different systems.
And so let's talk a little bit
about this problem and how it
sort of emerged
emerges over time.
We sort of call this the data
data downtime.
So data downtime
refers to periods of time when
your data is wrong,
inaccurate,
otherwise erroneous.
And the interesting
thing about
data downtime, again,
something that
everyone here is
likely experienced,
is that the impact of data
downtime actually is worse as
you kind of progress across
different stakeholders
in the organization
. So if you think
about a couple
of years ago,
maybe three, five,
ten years ago, there weren't
that many people
who were actually
working with data in
the organization.
And today, there's
data engineers,
data analytics, data science.
There might be ML engineers,
software engineers,
definitely you know,
teams that are working in in
business functions.
There's way, way,
way more people
that are actually
making use of the data.
And so if you think about sort
of the impact of
data being wrong,
at the starting point,
maybe when
the data engineering
team actually
catches that issue,
that is what you'd
call sort of
under control. However,
there might be a couple weeks
later that an issue
goes unnoticed,
and then that is discovered by
the data analytics or the data
science team, which might be
frustrating that we as data
engineers didn't catch
that issue first.
Maybe, you know,
worse over time,
that issue lingers or actually
starts to have
an impact across
the business.
Those can actually
have material impact
on companies,
on organizations,
on people. Right?
And so thinking
about companies
in media or in
retail or ecommerce
companies who really sort of,
are at material risk in terms
of compliance if
the data is wrong,
if you, you know,
mistakenly get credit card
information wrong.
You might be overcharging
customers or
undercharging customers.
You might be
powering the wrong
marketing campaign
with incorrect data.
The list is long. Right?
But the bottom
line is that data
data downtime
impacts all of us.
Its importance is rising in
organizations
because the impact
of data downtime,
is is severe over time.
And so, you know,
I come to you today with a lot
of bad news. I realize this is
a little bit of
a depressing start,
but I have some good
news for you all.
And the good news
is, actually,
in order to think about how do
we build reliable
data products,
it is helpful to look at,
a corollary or
look at our friend
software engineers
who who have
been building
reliable products,
for decades now. Right?
So how do engineers actually
approach building
reliable products?
You know, what
you can see here
is sort of, various categories
and various tools that have
built around each
of the categories
that ultimately help data help
engineering teams
build products
that are reliable,
secure, and scalable.
Now in data so far,
it's kind of been
the Wild West.
Right? Like, you get up,
spin snow spin up, Snowflake,
spin up Looker, and
you get started.
Everyone has access
to everything.
There's no test.
There's no monitors.
You put things in the wild,
and you hope that
they're okay.
Right? In a lot of
those instances,
data downtime rises and starts
to become more prominent in
organizations. So what can we
actually learn
from our friends
in software engineering?
At a very high level,
there's sort of three core
categories here that,
that emerge from this that we
would like to
actually implement
for data and to take as best
practices as well.
And these three categories at
a very high level,
the categories of discovering
problems as they arise,
resolving problems as
fast as possible,
and then preventing
them to begin with.
So, again, these
are all concepts
that are taken from software
engineering, but what do they
look like when we
apply them to data?
What does it mean to
actually discover,
when an issue is
detected when an issue,
sort of arises in data?
You know, I'll
say most often,
many data teams that we find
that we work with,
we find that they are the last
to learn about issues
arising in data.
So, you know, they
might sometimes
hear about it from
their internal
customers, say,
the marketing team or
the product team,
or support or customer
success team.
Oftentimes, they also learn
about this from
real customers,
external customers,
if you will,
not real external customers.
And in those cases,
they're caught blinded,
if you will,
learning about
an issue from others.
So how do we
actually turn this
around and develop
the tools so
that data teams are the first
to know and the first
to discover
about data issues.
A lot of that goes
into actually
setting up
monitoring, alerts,
strong anomaly detection,
and different things that that
we'll touch on.
Once you've
actually identified
that there is a problem,
how quickly does
it take you to
resolve it? Many
data teams that
we speak with, sometimes it
takes them weeks
or even months
to resolve an issue.
What if you had an approach to
actually resolving
data downtime issues,
in a way that
will allow you to
do it in minutes or in hours
instead of weeks or months?
And what does that look like?
What are some of
the root cause
analysis that you
need to do in
order to identify,
what exactly is the issue?
And then finally,
prevention. Right?
If we're doing this right,
we can actually
reduce the number
of incidents,
the number of data
downtime incidents
to begin with.
If we're actually
getting smarter
over time, if we're learning,
what are the, you
what are the main
sources or the main pipelines
that tend to break?
What are the main issues that
are causing data downtime that
are sort of draining
a lot of our time?
If we continue to
collect insight
and information about this,
we should ultimately
be able to
prevent these issues
to begin with.
So I very much
believe in actually
adopting the sort
of three three
step framework, that
we that, you know,
is tried, tested,
and proven in
software engineering
and now applying it
to data engineering.
So today, we don't
have time to
double click into each
in each of these,
but I will double click into
discover and talk
about some of
the methods that we've used,
that we've identified as sort
of best in class and that some
of the best organizations,
some of the strongest
data teams
are actually adopting in order
to improve the ability
to discover.
Now, you know, one of
the questions is,
how do we actually measure
ourselves on these three?
How do we know that
we've gotten better?
And so we're seeing more and
more data teams develop bet
better methods of actually
measuring themselves
on these.
To be honest, most data teams
don't measure
themselves today,
but, actually,
just starting to
measure is a great
step forward.
So on Discover, folks
actually look at,
time to resolution. Sorry.
It's time to detection.
So how quickly I'm
thinking ahead here.
So how quickly,
is there actually
what is the time
lapse between
when the incident
actually happened when we and
when we detected it?
That's sort of
the first metric.
The second metric is
around resolution.
And so once we have
detected an issue,
how quickly until
we resolved it?
And obviously, you know,
you sort of expect
that, you know,
incidents will happen,
but that over time,
we are improving in both of
those metrics.
And then the third
metric is prevention.
Are we able to
reduce the number
of incidents overall?
So actually
starting to measure
how many p one, p two,
p three incidents do we have?
What is,
what is the the time to detect
and time to resolution
per issue,
and are we able to
improve over time?
So that's just to
give you a little
bit of sense of how you can
measure yourself
as an organization
to improve this.
Now let's double click into
the discover part here,
the first portion,
and talk a little
bit about what
are the methods that
teams are using to,
really operationalize that as
part of improving,
their data operations and
minimizing data downtime.
So continuing to
borrow a little
bit some concepts
from software
engineering, there's a concept
called observability
in software
engineering,
which is yet again
a very well
understood concept,
which, you know,
if you check out this quote,
also has a lot to do with,
with monitoring as well.
And there's a lot that's been
written about the difference
between observability
and monitoring.
But in software engineering,
it's sort of like a no brainer
to have something
like this. Right?
And so the most
common things,
you know, talked about,
like metrics and
traces and logs.
And there's sort of a lot of
kind of solutions that enable
software engineers to do their
job in making sure
that applications
are, reliable.
So solutions like
PagerDuty and
Splunk and New
Relic and Datadog
are all solutions that we are
very accustomed to work with.
And in software engineering,
they make a lot of sense.
And so the question is,
in the data space,
why are we flying blind?
Why don't we have
something like
this that will allow us data
engineers to
actually do our job
properly? And so imagine that
you're actually
taking the concept
of observability
and now applying
that to data. What
does that look like?
So let's actually
define the term
data observability here so
everyone is on the same page.
Data observability
is an organization's
ability to
understand the state
and health of
the data in their
system with the objective of
mitigating data downtime.
Again, the the measure
of success
here is if we are
able to prevent
data downtime to begin with.
We probably won't
reach a hundred
percent. We will
not be perfect.
But if we can
actually minimize
it and reduce this,
we will all be able to spend
time elsewhere
on other revenue
generating projects,
or other things
that, you know,
we are curious and
excited about.
And so data observability,
barring again from the concept
of observability from software
engineering,
actually allows us
to understand,
to discover data
downtime issues,
ultimately increasing
trust in the data.
So continuing
down this path of
data observability,
what does data observability
actually mean? So in software
engineering, it's super well
understood and used.
In in data observability,
it's a new term. Right?
And so what we did at Monte
Carlo is actually we spoke to
hundreds of data organizations
ranging from small startups to
large organizations
like Netflix
and Facebook and
Uber and, actually,
sort of created a sort of or
collated really big dataset of
what are all
the reasons for why
data downtime happens to to
organizations, what are all
the symptoms that,
folks see when data
downtime happens,
and then all the reasons that
folks or all the ways in which
folks actually resolve
those issues.
And so we actually
codified all
of that good stuff
into what we
call the five pillars of data
observability. And
in our experience,
we see that when you actually
sort of put these
to work, when you,
instrument, monitor,
analyze these,
data teams are actually able,
to to start this
sort of journey
towards operationalizing
trust in data.
And and having
this combination
of these five
actually provides
a very strong view
into the health
of your data.
And for the first time,
data organizations
are actually
able to see,
to understand the health of
their data and
understand where
are the sort of vulnerability
spots and what are the areas
where some corrections need to
be implemented.
So let's double
click into each
of these briefly to
give you a little
bit of an example
of what these
data observability
pillars mean.
So starting with freshness,
which is the first
one, which,
freshness means
a lot of different
things. This is a particular
example of it. But really sort
of it comes down
to the timeliness
of the data. Right?
So in this example,
what you see here
is a specific
table that, you know,
the the lines here indicate
the table getting updated,
over sort of this,
axis of time here from from
November tenth onwards.
And you can see that the table
is getting
periodically updated
once or twice a day,
a couple of times a day.
And then suddenly,
there's a period of three or
four days with no
updates at all.
In this instance,
this might indicate that there
is a potential issue
with the data.
And so actually,
by using machine learning to
observe the data over time,
we're able to
identify these in
an automatic way.
And now, oftentimes,
data teams find themselves
manually specifying a lot of
these thresholds.
I'm happy to say with some
advances around
automation machine
learning, it is
actually possible
to do this, not only
for a particular
table, but rather for hundreds
of thousands of
tables at scale.
And so you can automatically
sort of turn on
a slew of metrics,
around sort of
the freshness of data,
this being one
example of them.
The second important pillar is
the concept of volume.
So pretty straightforward,
as you can see here,
an example where
you see a number
of rows. And in
this particular
incident, there's an unusual
number of rows that
were removed.
You can see there's
sort of a nice
trend. So slowly increasing
the number of rows
and row count.
And then suddenly,
on September thirtieth,
there's a very high number of
rows that have been removed.
So this is an example
of one way
to track volume.
And, again, another sort of
reason for why or another
indication for data might be,
that might be wrong.
The third sort of
pillar of data
observability is what
we call schema,
and schema is often
the culprit of data,
going wrong or going down.
Oftentimes, schema or actually
or schema changes,
they happen quite a lot,
but they're not
communicated about.
So one team might
make a change,
but then the other
team is unaware
of that. And oftentimes,
in that breaking point in
communication is where sort of
lies the data
downtime problem.
And so what we see data teams
do is actually
have an automated
way of tracking
schema changes.
And so in this example,
you see there's
a bunch of fields
that have been
completely deleted
and removed. There's probably
someone downstream
that has a report
or other tables
or another model
that actually relies on these
fields and needs to
be notified of this.
You might actually
have also a specific
field change in type,
which might impact
downstream.
And so having an automated way
to track these the changes in
schema and a way
to communicate
about them is a very,
very important part of this
fourth pillar.
And then the fifth
pillar is is,
or sorry. The fourth pillar is
distribution, and distribution
really has to do with metrics
and health at
the field level.
So as an example here,
you can see there's a field
called count pets
one five years old,
and we're looking at
percentage null.
And there's
a specific average,
a seventeen day average,
so a little less than three
weeks average.
And then today,
the percentage of
knowledge just spiked.
It's way higher
than the average
in the last, two
to three weeks.
And so in this
instance, you know,
this might be a field where,
it's it's it is
quite bizarre,
to have so many, so
many null values.
And so this might actually,
be an incident,
that you'd wanna look into.
And so this is
an example of a type
of distribution
issue, if you will.
And, again, there's
a whole you know,
under distribution,
you could look at null rates,
negative rates.
You could look at,
average, min,
max, a whole slew of different
metrics under distribution,
everything at
the field level.
And then the fifth
linea the fifth,
pillar here is
the lineage pillar.
It might be my favorite.
And this pillar
actually allows
us to bring the whole
story together.
So what you can see here is,
a table level lineage,
where you have,
tables from a data
warehouse and
then views downstream
in Looker.
And there's
a particular incident
that's been identified
in a particular
table called recent metrics.
And you can see all the tables
downstream and the views
and explores,
and dashboards downstream that
have been impacted by this.
Now the importance
of lineage,
both at the table level
and field level,
is that lineage by itself is
quite useless, to be honest.
So if you just have lineage,
there's not that much that you
can actually do with it,
or it's mostly sort
of eye candy,
for for most teams,
where we do find lineage being
helpful when it's
applied to a specific
use case.
And in this
particular use case,
it's around data
observability.
And so I think when you take
lineage and you combine that
with the sort of other pillars
that we talked about today,
that's really where
the magic lies.
So, you know, let's
say, for example,
there's a particular
table that
has a freshness problem.
So there's data that's loading
once an hour at any given day
and then data stopped loading
that table. It
hasn't been loaded
for three hours.
And then downstream
from that,
there's another
table that might
actually, as
a result of that,
have a problem has
a distribution
problem. And as
a result of that,
there might be a dashboard
downstream that might have
incorrect data now.
And so lineage helps us piece
all of that together and help
us make sense of, Okay,
there's a problem somewhere,
but should I care
about that problem?
Maybe there are
no dependencies.
Nobody's using this table,
so nobody cares about it.
So maybe, you know,
we don't care about
that specific
problem. However,
maybe there is
a specific incident
with hundreds of
tables downstream,
key reports that
your board and
execs and customers
are using,
in that instance,
you probably want to give that
incident a higher
degree of attention,
a higher degree of severity.
And so lineage is incredibly
powerful in helping us sort of
bring this together
and help us
understand both
on the one hand
impact assessment.
Should I care about this?
Who cares about this?
And then on the other hand,
it helps us understand root
cause analysis. Right?
So if there's a particular
incident somewhere,
what are the upstream sources
of that we can
learn from around
what might have gone
wrong and where?
So being able to answer all of
these questions is really
fundamental to our ability to
restore trust in data,
or to have more
trust in data,
if you will.
And so finding or sort of
developing ways to automate
the instrumentation
and the monitoring
of these and bringing them
together in one view is really
what helps us in
building towards
this new paradigm,
if you will,
this new data
reliability stack,
which includes
sort of the three
steps that we talked about.
And so when you
think about that
first step,
the discover step,
going back to kind
of the initial
prompt here,
most of our reality
today is a reality
where we created some tests to
test the things
that we know can
go wrong with our data,
and that's a very
important part
of our job. And then eighty
percent of our life is really
kind of getting
angry Slacks or
emails from colleagues
that are really,
really unhappy with some of
the data going
wrong or reports
getting messy or,
model drift.
There's all these things that
people can get
really angry at,
and then the finger pointing,
game starts.
You you know,
who actually owns
this table and
whose fault it is.
Right? That's the reality that
we all live in.
However, I think
there could be
a better way, and
the better way
has to do with observability.
With observability, you know,
you still have
tests that we've
created ahead of time.
However, there's
broad automated
coverage that we can achieve,
with observability for eighty
percent of the incidents.
So we start out
with a good base
of issues that are detected in
a way that we don't need to
specify manually,
but rather we can have this
broad coverage for.
Of course, we will always need
to have tests. There's always
going to be things
that, you know,
us as sort of folks closest to
the data would know best.
And it's very hard
for any machine
to actually learn
or for anyone
to do for us. And those will
always continue.
But with observability,
you can rely on sort of broad
base of coverage to help make
sure that you're
sort of starting
from a, from a good place.
And then I wish I could say we
could eliminate the angry text
completely, the angry
Slack messages,
but, you know, I do think that
there's probably a one percent
that will always
remain with us.
We we can try to minimize as
much as as possible and maybe
even laugh about it.
But that's sort of,
with observability,
the benefits that
data teams see.
And so going back to kind of
the three core components,
we talked a lot about Discover
and sort of what
that looks like.
We talked a little
bit about Resolve.
The five pillars of data
observability fit nicely into
both of these and really help
us have a starting point for
the data that we
need to do our
job well and to actually sort
of generate results here to
reduce time to detection,
time to resolution.
And then ultimately,
we'll talk more about this
potentially in
a future talk, But,
there's a lot of work more for
us to do on sort
of prevention,
as an industry overall.
I think we've made tremendous
progress in some
of these areas,
but I'm really excited for
developments in other
areas as well.
And so with that in mind,
data observability
is just getting
started. It's very
much a new term.
It's taken the world
by storm.
We're seeing more
and more data
organizations, implement this
as part of their,
part of their
operational work.
You know, team
syncs to actually
review some dashboards of how
we've improved in
time to detection,
time to resolution.
What are the main,
areas where we
where we're seeing
a higher incident
of data downtime
issues that we want
to work through?
What are the areas where we're
seeing an improvement?
What are the different teams
that are working with us that
we can actually have contracts
and SLAs with in
order to develop
a stronger
organization overall,
sort of going beyond the data
engineering team,
and including all
the stakeholders
that we work with.
So there's a lot more work for
us to to be done here.
I hope this gave you a little
bit of a taste of what data
observability actually is.
I hope you left with a better
sense of some
examples, you know,
maybe something that
you can implement,
and get started
on your journey.
If you'd like to reach
out, feel free.
This is a topic that I'm most
passionate about.
And if you have
an example or a story,
or a bad data horror
story to share,
would love to hear from you.
Thanks so much,
for having me,
and I'm looking
forward to the q
and a portion.